hi guys I'm Brent rose tech writer and
anthropomorphic crash-test-dummy so you
know how the Segway never really quite
caught on well there's a whole new breed
of wry tables here they're being
championed by the best and brightest
among us visionaries like Justin Bieber
Wiz Khalifa and jr. Smith are really on
board with these boards but do these
things really have a future or there's
something you could realistically ride
to work or are they dangerous death
machines that will fall apart if you
sneeze on them we're going to put them
to the test today
so let's find out so I've never tried
any of these things to test how easy
they are to learn I'm going to give
myself ten minutes on each of them this
is the funky duck it cost 1500 bucks
has a claimed range of 10 miles top
speed of 12 miles an hour is the one
most of the celebrities have been
messing around on for the last few
months turning is so hard oh we have to
lean into it
oh man with upbeat it's a speed limiter
Wow I have trouble imagining myself
writing this to work I already feel
relatively competent so this next one is
the hovertrax
looks a lot like the funky duck doesn't
it well the hovertrax actually came
first and they've got the patents to
prove it this one cost 1500 bucks as a
range of just 9 miles and goes only 5
miles an hour
feel that much slower really I feel like
I have way more control on this one okay
that's just me the first of many today
yeah I feel way more in control this one
scares the out of me this is the Z
board Pro it cost 900 bucks
it has a range of 13 miles and it can go
up to 20 miles an hour
good God now I've always been a truly
terrible skateboarder so tell my mom I
love her
hey hey you done it takes a much more
effort to turn this thing but it feels
more familiar to me no stopping is gonna
be the challenge lean back
ah oh yeah yeah that was
definitely a lot more challenging but it
was way more fun to the biggest weirdo
out of this whole field of weirdos has
got to be the solowheel extreme this
thing costs a whopping twenty three
hundred bucks it has a maximum range of
fifteen and a half miles and a top speed
of ten miles an hour it's basically a
self-balancing electric unicycle that
you stand up on so this should go well
God comes with this little like training
crotch strap
oh man definitely on right I'm worse
with the strap oh what the hell
drag was betraying me I want to love you
so bad I hate you so much right now
strap is back definitely easier with the
strap can taste it can't really taste it
I can smell it though yes little
skin it's gonna take a little more time
to get the hang of it
welcome to the time trial we've set up a
50 yard course we're gonna see which one
these things can get me through fastest
we've also got a radar gun clocking my
speed I've got all my protective gear on
even for a tech writer this is
considered very dorky come on 14 miles
an hour
oh man haha
yeah not good Oh goddamn 13 miles an
hour let's just address this point here
real quick their website says the top
speeds about 5 miles an hour I was going
13 on that thing I hit real hard there
okay let's see I'm okay to be fair this
one isn't really made for outdoor use
really really happy I had this on
alright let's try that one again
so squirrely hmmm 1365 eleven miles an
hour
it definitely feels cheekier at high
speeds 11 15 15 miles an hour yeah I
wouldn't fastest for sure it's hard to
shift your foot and you actually get
yourself stopping 13 miles an hour
that's fun
this thing is really growing on me well
that was intense I'd say overall the
solowheel took this one for me just felt
the most stable and the most secure at
speed followed closely by the z board
both of these other two where your your
have a wide parallel stance just felt
very strange when your direction of
travel is perpendicular next up we're
gonna look at handling we've set up a
little obstacle course and we're gonna
see which one can get me through the
quickest and the easiest oh Jesus God
hate that thing 2663 definitely felt
like I was in control head speed where I
wanted it 30:56 this is so much harder
to control this one at speed Yeow okay
okay
33:22 badass on the straightaway is
sharp turns not so much 1787 whoo this
was the hardest for me to learn on and
now I feel so much more comfortable on
this one and the other other ones too
bad it's so scented and for our last
challenge we have the curb test it's
pretty complicated I'm gonna drive these
off a curb Jesus oh good job funky duct
hovertrax
Oh again
Oh Zboard Oh God Oh
Breanna sticks the landing uh Breanna
was my old gymnast name I don't like to
talk about that all four of our boards
past the curb test I'm shocked frankly
nice to end on a high note so what did
we learn here today well all these were
pretty fun to ride I wouldn't say any of
them are really ready for daily
commuting between the two rivals the
hovertrax and the funky duck I have to
say I prefer the funky duck the wider
stance really helped a lot the Z board
was definitely fun to ride but
ultimately my overall favorite has got
to be the solowheel extreme it was the
hardest to learn but ultimately the most
satisfying it's just a lot of fun to
ride so what do you think are these
things you can use in your day-to-day
life or are these just toys for rich
kids let us know what you think in the
comments below subscribe to Wired if you
haven't already and with all that being
said there's really only one thing left
to do
Oh